here's a very special surprise one of
the greatest Oscar hosts of all time
someone I have even more respect for
right about now Billy Crystal
thank you thank you
No
Wow so where was I
some things never changed the producers
have asked me to tell you that we're
running a little long so here are the
nominees for Best Picture the first
televised Oscars was in 1953 I was 5
years old so for those of you stinking
math I'm 47 that's what it says in my
bio I'm 47 the host idea was Bob Hope
what a shock Bob hosted the show 18
times
I voted 8 and was pooped after - bob was
the Oscars he was funny he was classy
and he was what I think the Oscar host
must be a really sexy movie star drink
it in you
so as a kid watching that show every
year as we all did I want to be a
comedian want to be an actor but I
wanted to do what Bob Hope did so I
moved to California and bought land in
the valley I never worked with Bob Hope
I actually never met him but one night
we had a great moment together right
here on the stage of the Academy Awards
I was hosting the show Bob was sitting
right where Kevin sitting over there
with all the nervous people and I have
to tell you it made me a little jittery
that Bob Hope was in the audience well I
got off a good strong joke big laugh
bill - applause and I found myself
looking at Bob Hope right in Bob Hope's
face and the camera was on him and he
laughed and he applauded so I introduced
him and he blew me a kiss and gave me a
very affection little wave and it meant
the world to me and as soon as the
camera went away he flipped me off it's
true
so I guess you could say we did work
together and it was hilarious but that
was Bob Hope he was hilarious that was a
thrill every year to watch him at home
on television but can you imagine what
it must have been like to have been in
the audience when the great Bob Hope
hosted the Academy Awards from Hollywood
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences 25th annual Academy Awards
it's involved before
and thank you very thank you ladies and
gentlemen here we are once again welcome
to the Academy Awards or as as is known
at my house Passover
so the suspense here is fabulous and all
the plane thousands of voices saying
silently let it be me but if it can't be
me not him
all my losing tonight makes me a
two-time loser because due to some
repair work on Hollywood Boulevard my
stars now a manhole cover